so now according to nicole hannah jones
cubans are white did you know that
cubans are white now
why because they voted republican and
presumably as an increasing share of
venezuelans
but republican they too will become
white and the only people
who will not be white are the people who
vote nicole hannah jones wants them to
vote because in nicole hannah jones
world
the way that she uses white as a
stand-in for evil
and therefore if you are a cuban and you
voted for trump you are evil
thus you are white right this is pure
unbridled racism
that's the lady who founded the 1619
project and is the de facto editor
of the new york times she wasn't the
only person to say
nonsense like this there's a person
last night named andrea pino silva
who is a movement scholar author and
queer kubana
she tweeted out the cuban vote is not
the latino vote cubans have been sold in
narrative that they have a guaranteed
path to whiteness and many will sell out
every other minority to get it
trump's appeal is the appeal of white
supremacy doesn't matter he won an
increased share of black voters it
doesn't matter he won an increased share
of latino voters
none of that matters the only thing that
matters is that if you voted for trump
it is because you are a it is because
you are a
vicious brutal racist al sharpton
another vicious racist who has a slot
over on msnbc he said this last night
he said the cuban voters are just stupid
that's what happened human voters bought
the socialist propaganda that
that joe biden and kamala harris were
socialists okay well it turns out
that they bought into it because
democrats have embraced that label
bernie sanders
calls himself a socialist democrats call
themselves
progressives which in many south and
latin american countries
is a synonym for socialist that is their
fault
but here's al sharpton pretending that
cubans are just stupid that's why
they're voting for trump
we don't have the same dynamics that we
have in florida
where you have like in miami-dade i
think it was joy pointing out a large
cuban influence in terms of cuban voters
who look more uh uh to the propaganda
that
we're dealing with socialism and all
that offset a large black turnout
okay so again it's all about it's all
about the supposed whiteness
problem arne duncan the former education
secretary under barack obama tweeted out
last night we should stop talking about
red and blue we should start talking
about whiteness
they're not gonna let go of this not in
any way shape or form so if you think
your media are gonna
suddenly learn a lesson wrong you are
the same media who have been lying to
you and honestly i don't know how to
read the polls being
this wrong nationally except that these
people either
are in such a deep bubble that they have
internalized their own inability
to pull trump voters and then pretended
that they live in a universe of their
own making
or this was a lot of push pulling right
there there's a lot of polling that was
designed to disintegrate trump support
particularly
in battleground states by saying that
states like wisconsin and michigan were
out of reach
okay but the media are not going to
shift their story the media have a
narrative the media have an agenda
and we need to replace them the media
were worth
a minimum of five to ten points for joe
biden in this election if we're not for
the media that is a minimum
if it were not for the media if the
media had covered donald trump honestly
if the media had covered politics
honestly if the media weren't damned
liars in pursuit of an agenda donald
trump would have won easily last night
easily because even if donald trump
loses we're going to be talking about
donald trump losing by a combined total
of probably under 100
000 votes in pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin and arizona
and nevada right this is it's an
extraordinarily
close election did you know that every
like on this video creates one
additional leftist tier don't ask me why
that's called science to take advantage
of this amazing opportunity hit the like
button